let's go with Brandi next in
Pennsylvania hi Brandi how are you hi hi
good how are you
better than I deserve how can I help
okay so I just started your class about
three weeks ago at our church five we
started on a Wednesday by Friday I had
my emergency fund so baby step one was
done I'm typically the nerd of the two
of us well done
kind of recording that money I was
hoarding that money so I put an
emergency fund so now look baby step two
with the snowball the only that we have
is we're not the only bet but the only
that that we're paying on right now that
we have our two vehicles but everything
else is already in collections how do I
handle that what do you owe in these two
cars well we just bought them both this
year between 35 and 40 each no no
together okay and what's your household
income a little over 50 okay you have
too much in cars say it again you have
too much in cars I know
so which one which one are we going to
sell okay and so what is his car worth
twelve oh not much yeah so you have the
expensive car well yes
yeah I have a minivan oh okay well the
total of your vehicles in value even if
they're paid off should never be more
than half your annual income so when you
finish in the smoke clears you don't
have over $25,000 tied up in cars if you
make 50 grand okay and your dadgum van
is closed what are you gonna put him in
a thousand dollar car while you drive a
twenty nine thousand dollar car um I
don't know if we have to well we could
go another direction and that sell your
stupid van
true yeah because it's the bigger
problem of the two you have thirty seven
thousand dollars in debt what is owed on
his twelve thousand dollar car that it's
twelve it's owed o twelve old and twelve
value she can break even on it for the
most part yeah okay so you owe twenty
five thousand on this man yeah okay
you're not gonna like me telling me that
your car is taking up all of the car
value that you should guys should have
tied up in other words again coming back
when you finish you should have cars not
worth more than twenty five thousand
dollars you owe 25 on this van what is
it worth probably not much more than
that
yeah about that yeah and so that means
so if you have a twenty-five thousand
dollar van and you shouldn't have more
than 25 thousand dollars tied up in
vehicles he's walking right your vans
gone it doesn't make sense to your
family you bought too much paint it
doesn't make sense to the family and it
clears up a bunch of your debt so that's
what I would do again I later on you'll
be making more money you'll have more
money you'll drive whatever you wanna
drive but Sharon and I we drove like no
one else so later we could drive like no
one else I Drive whatever I want to now
but back then I drove a hoopty you know
to get my butt out of debt and to get
this stuff straightened out and so you
pay a price to win and you just you just
got all impulse tup and mama bear and
Mama Bear want a van for the kids and
with all the goodies for the kids and
protect the children because it's safe
and all this stuff and you do all these
through all these rationalizations that
we all go through and you bought too
much fan I'm sorry I'm sorry
I love you I hope you still love me show
your van I just saved your husband